David how did it come about it came I
know from the the gentleman who has a
cold and is not with us it did in early
2013 right after I'd had a feature at
Sundance for the first time I was sent
this article from The New Yorker called
the old man the gun along with a note
asking if I'd be interested in meeting
with mr. Redford to discuss adapting it
based on the fact that you called him
mr. Redford I'm gonna guess you did not
you did not know him I did not know him
I've been in the same room with a herd
of him I had seen Captain America is his
most famous film of course right now but
I don't really remember too much of that
first meeting because I was well I was
definitely starstruck and but I do we
talked about you know being from Texas
which is where I'm from and where he's
from and we talked about the story I'm
sure at some point in there but you know
the next day I sat down and start
writing it and was writing it with him
in mind every step of the way as long as
you mentioned writing it with him in
mind every step of the way The New
Yorker article which is a wonderful read
there is no love interest there is no
jewel in the story so who did you have
in mind as you wrote that part into your
film she's sitting right here there
there was a character in the story whom
like a wealthy widow character who he
married in real life the real horse
sucker McCann within the span of a few
months met wooed and married this woman
whose name was jewel and one of the
great details of that relationship
actually the only detail that really
comes through in the story is that she a
said she never realized what he did
really did for a living but also she was
really wealthy so he married into a very
wealthy country club lifestyle and yet
couldn't stop robbing banks which I saw
III thought that said a lot about him
but I wanted the jewel in our film to do
more than that I wanted her to go toe to
toe and you know really sort of
give him an opportunity to pursue
something else to go down a different
path and then to as per the real story
and not do that and when I was writing
it I I always like to write for actors
that I know and sometimes I take the the
risky chance of writing one for someone
I don't know but who I do really want to
work with and so thankfully you liked it
so you wrote it for [ __ ] and you'd
never met her either nope but I was from
Texas oh yeah we basically we basically
our neighbors
so then Cissy how did that how did it
come to you how did you receive this
work did we meet first and then we
Skyped we Skyped we I don't think we
actually meant person until you came to
location but we had Skyped and talked on
the phone and and all the things that
people do in modern times had I read the
script before you I think so because we
talked about the jewelry store scene I
remember like right from the very
beginning we talked about that and you
gave me a great bit of advice about how
to make it much better which I
thankfully took don't steal the bracelet
yeah basically be a good person
oh so you changed that that the
originally sheep goes along with
originally I wanted jewel dad where she
participates in the thrill of it and I
didn't have the foresight to realize
that the scene needed to continue and
that forest needed it to be put in his
place and realized how to be a
responsible mature human being and Cissy
illuminated that for me I think I think
he liked jewel a lot better after that
she beat him at his own game so and got
the bracelet so says he before I move on
to the other panelists here you um you
had met your co-star in this film but
you guys had never acted together and
you had no personal relationship right
and the wonderful thing was was that we
shot all of jewels most of hers often
except one scene at the very end of the
movie we shot it in the beginning of the
filming when it was just us there and so
we our relationship we we got to know
each other on film and
and through the scenes so it really got
to unfold and that's something that
rarely happens getting to shoot in
pretty much in sequence Chico
what was your experience then on this
production with three three Academy
Award winners and this rising acclaimed
I've never used the word acclaimed out
loud and I just did it and this rising
heralded director yeah it was surreal I
just remember sitting in a diner at the
diner and we were just on these booths
and I'm just looking around like holy
hell like they all wanted Academy Award
and it was just amazing but I came in
and it was literally like a family I've
never worked with David before obviously
as a director and he was just so
welcoming of our ideas and Kasey and I
never met either so he didn't know if
there would be chemistry but he made it
really good guess and he made it so they
both made it so comfortable and
inclusive of my ideas and Casey's ideas
that the family actually felt lived in
and it felt like it was real and I think
we accomplished something there may I
just say that you know a movie set like
despite being here at the Academy I have
to say that once you get on a movie set
no matter what Awards people have or
whatever how many great movies have been
in it is all pretty quickly forgotten
and you're just sort of looking and
dealing with the other person that's
there and teeka's being modest I think
she came in and completely just owned
the set and those scenes and and brought
our storyline to life in a really great
way so I don't think you know once I
started acting it was like you know to
watch Bob like read a newspaper and
[ __ ] was just like laughing and
everybody was just being normal human
beings it was like oh cool they're
people so big advantage of this movie
Lisa as you and David are putting
together
I learned upstairs moments ago Robert
Redford almost in the same
outfit the entire movie David had this
brilliant idea of dressing Bob in a blue
suit through the entire film maybe
changing a tie or something like that
we had like a my my wonderful costume
designer Nell Broder who had like an
entire series of like slightly different
blue suits depending on you know the
mood or the tone and the tie would
change and like this
the shirts but sometimes be tea stained
or not and often I just feel like we
can't ask him to go change like let's
just keep shooting but but what that
gave us was total freedom in terms of
the editorial process of moving scenes
around restructuring a lot of things
went back many things went back to the
way that they were originally written
but it gave us the freedom to experiment
in a way that you normally can't do you
can with visual effects you can change
certain kinds of things I've done that
before added a skirt you know Donna's
shirt but this was just very organic in
terms of being able to really find the
true structure of the movie and the
other thing I wanted to say is that it
was really interesting that we did which
is highly unusual
we worked without music for most of the
editorial process which is really
unusual and not for me not unusual for
me right
but unfortunately had done Pete's dragon
we had done this huge attempt score and
stuff like that so it was a really
wonderful discovery for me to be able to
find the rhythms of the scene without
you know music telling you what to do
you like that that was oh I loved it I
absolutely loved it it's a way to find
out what the movie is before you start
finishing it because like music is an
amazing tool but if I find that if you
put it in too early you start to lean on
it and I would rather let the movie like
inform me of its own rhythm before we
start trying to augment or illuminate
that rhythm with with music sissie you
make a lot of cozy movies the so I want
to know for all you guys but but so you
know the other narrative that developed
here and and and he wishes he could take
it back that it was announcing that it
was red for its last movie as an actor
and so it's interesting that in a sense
this is now I'm glad he's not here I'm
tired
tired of that guy but that that
narrative developed during the
production right you became aware not in
the first part but when you're shooting
that maybe this was gonna be his final
it was during prep that he had and he
had done an interview and I can't
remember where it was but it started to
pop up in my phone like Robert Redford
just announced his retirement yeah he's
like over there a sandwich reading the
paper yeah so it was definitely
something we were aware of as a
possibility and I just instantly just
was like I'm not gonna think about that
because otherwise it'll just inform
everything I'm doing to a degree that I
think would be unhelpful for the film
you just like I didn't want to go
through every scene thinking well that's
the last time Robert Redford is ever
gonna like get out of a car in a movie
that's the last time he's gonna hang up
a pay phone he uses pay phones like
nobody else I know buddy nobody better
on a telephone than Redford in a movie
and and so I just didn't think about it
at all ever but then once we you know
finished the film and and and then
certainly in the past few weeks as he's
talked about it more it certainly has
been something that has been on my mind
and as a fan I certainly hope he keeps
acting if he decides that he's gonna
move into other territory as he talks
about we want to direct and produce more
and and focus on his his other interests
then I certainly understand it but you
know for me is some a fan who grew up
watching him as an actor I don't want to
ever have the opportunity to not see a
new Robert Redford movie
sissie did you you're you know if it is
his final movie this is you or the you
were the love interest you I got the
last kiss you got the last kiss so did
this story break while you guys were
still shooting your scenes sir you know
I don't remember it was it was like in
November of the fateful November of 2016
so we why what else happened I can't
remember it was I got really distracted
by this and retired ever there was a
Thanksgiving that yeah that's a good one
and so we were in prep we were like
location scouting at that point so it
was before anyone had got into town and
I think by the time we started shooting
a few months later it had receded to the
point where we didn't ever have to talk
about it